this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 10. with Echo Charles and me
Jocko willink
good evening good evening all right so
today we have some q a some q a some
questions that are specifically from
members of the Jocko Underground
that are on board for the big win
and part of the reason we set up the
Jocko underground.com was so that we
could
hone down the number of people that
submit questions and get to more of them
so that's what we're doing here so Echo
Charles what do we got let's get to it
in the British army there has been a
rise in right-wing views and support to
the point where soldiers are being
counseled
and in a few cases sacked for their
views that's fired I will translate that
from British yeah oh yeah uh as service
members when in uniform we're supposed
to be politically neutral is it
impossible to maintain this position in
today's climate
okay so good question
and first of all in
well speaking of the American Military
this idea that you can be an extremist
of any kind is not okay you're not
allowed to the the according to the
Pentagon military personnel must reject
participation in organizations that
espouse supremist causes attempt to
create illegal discrimination based on
race Creed color sex religion or
national origin Advocate the use of
force or violence or otherwise engage in
efforts to deprive individuals of their
civil rights so that's a very
comprehensive list that means you can't
be in any basically in any kind of gang
because because you know you're not
allowed to use force or violence that's
what gangs do you're not allowed to
the one that's really a catch-all is
deprive individuals of their civil
rights you know what that means you
committing crimes against anyone so if
you're part of a criminal gang you're
not allowed to be part of a criminal
gang and you're not allowed to be part
of any kind of a supremacist
organization
and you're not allowed to do that in the
American Military and I'm sure it's the
same in the British Military and guess
what yeah good we don't want people in
the military that we have to serve with
that are criminals or associated with
criminal games or they're extremists or
they're racist
foreign
now
it might just be the wording of your
question and
I I'm assuming
that what you're talking about is more
along the lines of sort of the cancel
culture type situation that
is going on in in the world and in some
cases people are being counseled or
fired for things that are not wrong
and then that's different so if you know
the way the question is worded is like
oh there's been a rise of right-wing
views
and and if that's it's right-wing views
okay but if it's right when extremist
views or racist views it's like okay
well yeah you're not allowed to be in
the military
you have the right to have those views
but you don't have the right to be in
the military
now
if it's like oh you have some
conservative views and now people are
getting counseled for it and that's what
we're talking about yeah okay I get it
or if you're a super liberal person and
you have some beliefs that are a little
a little bit outside what's normal and
you're getting counseled for it
well yeah that's wrong now most of I
would say most of the cancel culture
right now is
aimed at conservative people
so
this is what's happening not just in the
military but in the whole world right
now and here's the thing I just did an
unraveling podcast about
well it's not directly about this but
it's about a an event that is reflective
I would say so Daryl Cooper and I just
did a
a podcast about the witch hunts in Salem
Massachusetts and it's it's not I don't
think it's out yet he's still editing
but
there's also witch hunts throughout
history and they many of them have the
same kind of
it's a similar Arc of the story so
here's what happened in Salem I mean
just you can listen to that podcast when
it comes out but
the the witch hunts in Salem
were started by two girl little girls
one that was nine and one that was 12.
and what they figured out
is they could get people in serious
trouble by accusing them of being
witches but by accusing them of
bewitching
so they would they would act crazy and
scream and yell and throw stuff around
the room and then point at someone and
say that person possessed me
and actually the first person that they
did it to was was a slave that they had
this this woman named I think her name
was Tituba
and they blamed her for their actions
and so she gets accused as a witch and
and the little girls are like who knows
what they expected but then all of a
sudden they see that they have what do
they have they have powerless little
nine-year-old and 12 year old girl all
of a sudden they have power
and then what happens
so it starts to expand they start
accusing other people and by the way and
again you can compare this to cancel
culture If you defend a witch what are
you which you're a witch too you're a
witch no you're a witch straight up yeah
you're a witch so then it spreads and
then what happens is that the only way
to be safe from being accused as a witch
do you know how you defend yourself I
have no idea accuse other people oh yeah
yeah you can see where do you see where
this is going yeah this is this is where
the term Witch Hunt comes from
so this this runs wild and it becomes a
mob mentality and that's what happened
in Salem and and hundreds of people were
imprisoned
20 people were executed
executed
because
of a nine-year-old and a 12 year old and
actually what's what's crazy is other
little girls got in on the ACT
other little girls got in on the ACT and
this is what you have to remember about
mobs
mobs are very destructive but
they end up destroying themselves
so they're like this this burning fire
that they they will burn themselves out
and that's what happened in Salem the
the accusations kept going
and eventually they started accusing
people that were either of a little bit
more
of more Social Power because let's face
it when they accused Tituba the slave
no one really cared right but then they
started accusing non-slaves and then
they started accusing they went up the
social hierarchy and eventually they got
to a point where they were accusing
people and they said we're not listening
to you so they literally just started uh
shot up like where they started ignoring
the girls and the girls now that they
weren't getting the attention anymore
guess what they did
they stopped doing it
they stopped doing it and then
everything settled down and that was it
and it was kind of it just kind of ended
it just kind of happened and ended
now it's scary because there was some
serious damage you know people were
executed but it ran its course and that
was that now I would love to give you
some advice
some you know Super Hyper aggressive
advice about stand your ground and you
got to do this but look there's a mob
happening
there's a mob happening
and when there's a mob happening
the you you have to recognize and
understand that the mob is going to
destroy itself if you get wrapped up in
the mob you could get destroyed too
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just just assistance
at Jocko underground.com and we'll get
you taken care of until then we will see
you mobilized
Underground